AND THE COUNTRY AFFECTED IS
FIGHTING BACK.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE HAS
DETAILS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THESE TARIFFS ARE TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE'S DECISION TO
IMPLEMENT NEW TARIFFS ON STEEL
AND IMPORTS FROM CANADA, MEXICO,
AND THE EUROPEAN UNION COULD FAN
THE WINDS OF A GLOBAL TRADE WAR
OR SEND A STRONG MESSAGE THAT
THE DAYS OF MASSIVE U.S. TRADE
BALANCE IS AN UNFAIR AND
ACCURATE SOMATIC MARKET ACCESS
ARE OVER.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE
ARGUMENTS ON LOGIC AND COMMON
SENSE AND HOPE THAT THEY WILL
PREVAIL AGAINST AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT DOES NOT
ALWAYS ALIGN ITSELF AROUND THOSE
PRINCIPLES.
>> IT IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE
THAT THE COUNTRY IS IMPOSING
THESE MATTERS.
>> GLOBAL TRADE IS NOT A
GUNFIGHT AT O.K. CORRAL.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S MOVE COMES
AFTER FAILED MONTHS OF
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCING TODAY
THAT TARIFFS OF 25% ON STEEL AND
10% ON ALUMINUM IMPORTS FROM
CANADA, MEXICO, AND THE E.U. ARE
SAID TO GO IN EFFECT AT
MIDNIGHT.
>> HE HAS WORKED TO EXEMPT
CERTAIN ALLIES FOR WHICH WE HAVE
TRADING OR SECURITY
RELATIONSHIPS.
BUT IN THESE INSTANCES, IT WAS
NOT POSSIBLE.
SO THE PRESIDENT TOOK ACTION.
>> IN RETALIATION MEXICO SAID IT
WOULD TARGET THE U.S.
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS.
AND CANADA ANNOUNCED A
$16 BILLION SET OF NEW TARIFFS
ON AMERICAN GOODS.
SOME OF THE PRESIDENT'S OWN
PARTY QUESTION THE WISDOM OF THE
POLICY, TENNESSEE SENATOR LAMAR
SAYING THAT THIS IS A BIG
MISTAKE, CALLING TARIFFS
BASICALLY HIGHER TAXES ON
AMERICAN CONSUMERS.
THE BEN SASSE OF NEBRASKA ADDING
THAT THIS IS DUMB.
TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
SHOULD NOT MEAN MAKE AMERICA
1929 AGAIN.
BOTH MEN ARGUED WHEN IT COMES TO
TARIFFS, THE U.S. SHOULD HIT
CHINA, NOT AL OUR ALLIES.
OBER ROSS SAID THAT HE WAS NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ROW.
>> THIS HAS BEEN UNDER
DISCUSSION FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
AND IT IS A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE RESPECTED
ECONOMY.
A FRACTION OF 1%.
>> CHINESE LEADERS SEE THE
ANTICIPATING TARIFFS SOON,
VOWING TO FIGHT BACK WHEN THEY
HAPPEN.
DO NOT FORGET NEXT WEEK, BRET,
WE WILL BE IN CANADA FOR WITH